this is an exciting moment for AI here
in Canada we are facing a historical
opportunity and responsibility to
harness the potential of AI to drive
economic growth and improve social
outcomes Canada is ai's birth place and
I'm proud to say that much of the
seminal work happened and continues to
happen right here in Toronto among
Canada's early Investments was the
founding of the vector Institute led by
our chief scientific adviser Jeffrey
Henton with the support of the
government of Canada the government of
Ontario and Industry Partners Vector
helped make Ontario a hub of AI
Excellence that has Spilled Out across
Canada leading to the tremendous growth
of our AI industry last year alone more
than 8.6 billion in Venture Capital
funding was invested in Canadian AI
companies that's 30% of all Canadian VC
activity that is a stunning number for
an industry that didn't even exist less
than a decade ago generative AI is
already transforming the way we work and
play Canada's home to many generative AI
focused companies at Vector were highly
focused on helping Canadian industry
adopt and commercialize AI we work with
our industry Partners to give their
teams unique access to expert
researchers exceptional training and a
sandbox environment that allows them to
experiment with new AI Technologies they
know that partnering with Vector they
gain unparalleled access to an AI talent
pool that really sets the bar for the
rest of the world AI holds tremendous
promise to improve our daily lives our
society and our economic prospects as
long as we do it responsibly this moment
in AI in Canada really excites
[Music]
me